[Music]
right here
my name is leilani cannot well Huggins
and I'm Ally maker I grew up actually
here in Los Angeles I'm a fourth
generation Lea maker and I was raised in
Hawaii till I was six my mom and my
Hawaiian side of the family just made
sure I was immersed in the Hawaiian
culture and from a young age I was
making lei and like all cultures flowers
are symbolic of purity and celebrate
celebration you don't go anywhere
without giving away without giving
someone a part of you it's you're giving
a part of yourself
traditionally Hawaiian leis are woven
with love and aloha and the method used
is just as important as the flower
that's used
the ideal clipping is just something
that's beautiful that's not bruised or
damaged and that's not dried out yet
there's a few dried out pieces here
probably from the wind and the cold that
we've been having in LA this is like
very relaxing to just finding the
flowers flower therapy flower therapy I
like it we sort of clip it closer to the
branch so it promotes growth and that we
will clean up these branches when we get
back to the house so I picked this
flower because I'm learning from Leilani
that you want to cut from the stem and
then we can do most of the work later
but I thought I think most people will
think of that beautiful purple
Dendrobium orchid lay is as Hawaiian but
those are made and usually come from
Thailand right now there is a fungus
that is ravaging the Big Island and
Hawaii it's called rapid Ohia death and
it's basically the Metro City Rose
polymorpha plant they're everywhere here
in Los Angeles in Hawaii their treasured
it is nice to have those because in
Hawaii they're not using them right now
just real small links we're gonna cut
them down right here I'm gonna reach
under you this is gonna be the Oh Paula
so Paula means trash I feel like when
you're learning how to make leis you are
also learning a lot about the Hawaiian
culture yeah Maile pull did I say this
process is very relaxing
educational and just fun it's very
therapeutic
it feels very effortless but knowing
that I'm going to create something with
love and give it with love is just a
really great feeling Wow
the colors are so vivid
alleged purple it's so pretty it's gonna
look great on Instagram Instagram or
didn't happen did you both learn from
her yeah she's the master we're gonna
take a couple pieces of raffia some
people use yarn you use kind of whatever
you can get so we're gonna Qt and just
we're just gonna make a small slip
thought towards the end we're gonna wind
our flowers all together to make a label
[Music]
lay symbolize love it's yourself you're
giving of yourself you're giving of your
time you're giving for birthdays for
celebrations for anniversaries for
coming and going you give it to show
love and respect and honor I learned how
to I learned how to deal E and I'm
wearing this beautiful label yes and I
feel like a princess
yeah and I'm learning